Seid mal alle still, hier kommt Florentin Will.
Ich mach doch keine Witze, hier ist doch Stefan Titzel. Und wenn euch jemand fragt, was hörst du so, dann ist die Anfang nur Podcast-Ufo, gemischtes Haar, Radio Nukula. Schön, dass ihr da seid. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe des Pufo-Podcast-Projektes, natürlich mit Stefanoth.
Das Podcast-Ufo-Projekt.
Podcast zwei.
Zwei, ja. Über das Herste reden wir nicht.
Nein, das haben wir gelöscht.
Mein Name ist trotzdem noch Stefan Tietze, auch wenn wir da überlegt haben, wollen wir den Namen nochmal ändern oder nicht.
Wie viele Leute geraten haben, den Namen zu ändern für diesen Neugelang.
Anwälte, die Herren Anwälte.
Oh, die Anzugträger, die Kofferträger.
Die White Collars. Ich nenne sie ja die Kofferschlepper, die Schriftschlepper. So nenne ich sie ja, wenn ich in den Richtssaal steige. Die schlägt so viele Akten mit. Ich habe diesen Witz gemacht, wie viele Akten schlägt ihr mit und die haben gesagt, ja, the jokes on you, das sind ihre Strafakten. Ja, ja, ja, ja, blub, blub, blub, blub. Ja, genau. Und worum die will. Ja, schön, dass ihr da seid. Paul hat uns mit vielen Reimen beglückt am Anfang dieser Folge. Vielen Dank dafür. Es gibt noch ein paar Reime, sie sind noch nicht alle weg. Und er hat anscheinend eine Gitarre. Gut gemacht. Gut gemacht, ja. Es wurde jetzt wieder neue Farbe entdeckt, was für uns ja immer interessant ist. Wichtig ist, ja. Du hast dir direkt ein T-Shirt in Lisa geholt. Ja, dir muss jetzt direkt irgendeine, wie nennt man das, Himmelsrichtung, Farb, Himmelsrichtung, Farbsaison, die man haben kann, kriegt jetzt eine neue Farbe zugewiesen. Was ist die neue Farbe? So ein Mint. Also wenn du die neue Farbe mit einer alten Farbe beschreiben kannst. Und Mint ist auch nicht wirklich eine Farbe. Mint ist eine Geschmacksrichtung, zum Beispiel von einem Wassereis, das wir gerne essen im Sommer. Saure Drachenzungen habe ich mir hinein georgelt. Warum ist Mint dieses, ist es gar nicht, grünes Weitmeister? Dieses Fakiesgrün. Ja, wenn Mint eigentlich relativ direkt grün ist. Minze einfach ein ganz normales Tannengrün ist. Missverstanden ist Kraut, die Minze. Und dann sagt sie, hey, das ist doch deine Lieblingsfarbe, wir haben dir neuen Sweater geschenkt und so, Minze so, das ist halt, so sehe ich halt, nehmt ihr mich so wahr, also ist das, bin ich das so? Ja, das freut so aus. Okay, weil eigentlich, wenn ich mich so im Spiel betrachte, dann sehe ich eigentlich ganz anders aus, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, aber Selbstwahrnehmung, Fremdwahrnehmung ist immer ein spannendes Thema. Ja, jetzt nehmen wir dich so wahr. Und einfach so einen kackbraunen Pulli, Sweater. Auch schön, Herbstfarben. Ich werte nicht von Farben. Alle Farben sind gleich schön. Ja, dein Blick wertet. Genau, wurde eine neue Farbe entdeckt und warum nicht auch, wenn eine neue Farbe entdeckt werden kann, dann kann auch eine neue Geschmacksrichtung entdeckt werden, ein Geruch kann noch kennengelernt werden.
Also jetzt geht es ja dann wieder los und wir haben uns gefragt, wie kann das denn sein? Alle Farben gibt es doch mal. Auch spannend übrigens ist das Kartell, gibt es auch, glaube ich, eine spannende Doktor über Pantone. Ja, die Farbe, die Farben. Pantone hat ja nicht, man kann ja keine Farben setzen, sondern hier haben wir die Bezeichnung der Farben. Und ich glaube, die, es kostet inzwischen sehr viel Geld, wenn man Pantone, das war bei unserem Merch, war man da auch plötzlich bei Problemen, was ist denn die Pantone-Farbe, das Merch, wir brauchen die Pantone-Farbe eurer, eurer Strift zu, das Podcast-Projekt, hinten auf der Pulli, was ist das für eine Pantone-Farbe, habe ich gesagt, weiss ich jetzt nicht. Aber kann man die Farbe nicht auch ganz technisch einfach so als Wellenlänge angeben, also so ganz physikalisch, so ganz …
Ja, ja.
Also jetzt ohne dieses Holiday Miami Malibu Blue oder irgendwie sowas, sondern einfach, wir wollen halt einfach vierundundsechzig Hertz. Hey, Sir, Sir, you listen to me now. It's a Wellenlänge. It's a simple Wellenlänge … Ja, noch an die Pantone-Farbe, Herr Dietze. Ja, genau. Ist viel so ein Satz wie, ja, wir können aber keine Wellenlänge drucken oder sowas. Weißt du, wie ich meine? Okay, also du kannst die Wellenlänge, wir könnten technisch, wir könnten die Wellenlänge singen, wir könnten die Farbe wiederum singen, das geht, das ist kein Problem. Überhaupt kein Problem, da haben alle Geräte hier, siehne Problema. Aber drucken, das geht nicht.
Nee, das kannst du komplett vergessen.
Da hilft mir auch mein Rhetorik-Kurs 1 nicht, mein Rhetorik-Kurs 2 nicht.
Ja.
Ich habe wiederholt, sitzen geblieben.
Aber gute Frage, müssen Frauen nicht eigentlich null Problema sagen?
Also wenn normalerweise sagst du, ey, kannst du mir noch irgendwie einen Angie-Drink mitbringen vom Kiosk?
Null Problemo, müsste man nicht null Problema sagen Frau, Null Problema, die Obregada. Im Theater ist es ja so, da ruft man Bravo, Bravo, aber wer sich auskennt bei einer Schauspielerin, ruft Brava, Brava, also zu einer Frau. Genau, gibt es jetzt zum Beispiel bei den Wahlküren, dann kommen wir, die Wahl Wahlküren auf die Welt verbeugen sich. Da müsste man dann Braweh sagen. Braweh? Braweh? Aber müsste man dann, wenn man jetzt sagt, null Problemo, muss man nicht der angesprochenen Person gegenüber. Weil die hat ja kein Problem. Oder ich habe kein Problem. Wenn du sagst, null problemo. Wenn Alf, also Alf sagt, du pass mal auf, du bist ein fremdes Alien, du hast keinen Pass, willst du nicht mal wieder zurückkehren zu deinem Planeten und er sagt, nee, null problemo. Nee, problemi. Ach gut, da ist natürlich das kritisch schlecht, ne? Alf ist ja... Nee, wir haben aber eine klassische Holzweg-Thematik gerade hier. Ja? Also eine klassische, du bist auf dem Holzweg-Thematik, weil es ist ein Sprachding. Ach so. Italienisches Problemo, spanisches Problema. Ach so, was sagt das über die Kulturen aus wiederum? Das ist eine interessante Frage, da würde ich gerne mal reingehen. Lass uns mal reingehen. Da können wir doch so eine zwölfteilige SWR-Serie machen. Du verbringst zwölf Tage in Spanien, ich verbringe zwölf Tage in Italien. Nee, oder erst bin ich sechs Tage in Spanien, du sechs Tage in Italien. Dann fahren wir und wir treffen uns an der Grenze. Andorra. Andorra, tauschen aus die Ersteindrücke nach sechs Tagen, dann wechseln wir die Länder und dann fahren wir wieder zurück, treffen uns wieder und wechseln dann nach weiteren sechs Tagen unsere Erlebnisse aus und dann gehen wir ins Bett. Was? Dann legen wir uns erstmal hin. Den Part mag ich. Den Part können wir statt der Doku machen. Das finde ich auch gut. Wir können die Doku anschauen. Ah, super. Auch gut. Und dann gehen wir direkt ins Bett. Gemeinsam im Bett. Jetzt ist aber schon recht spät, jetzt halbe zehn, komm mal auf. Komm, jetzt mach ins Bett. Komm, jetzt mach doch Mikro mal aus. Mach mach die Mikro mal, schall dich mal aus, geh ich ins Bett. Ich finde aber geil eine Doku, die so beginnt, warum heißt das eigentlich, genau, wie beeinflussen Wörter die Kultur oder andersrum und so und so ein Scheiß halt und wir driften währenddessen aber ab mit unserem Problemchen auf der Reise. Sonnenkreben, ja. Ich bin ja so ein klassisches Problemkind dann auch, habe ich mir Blasen gelaufen. Ach, Kacke. Und dann die Kamera immer dabei. Und eigentlich geht es um diese, warum heißt es denn hier Problema und da Problemo. Aber auf dieser Reise, deswegen ist sie auch zwölfteilig, driften wir immer mehr in unsere Abgründe und eigenen Probleme rein. Und dann irgendwie einer verliebt sich auf der Reise und dann, oh, was ist denn da? Er bleibt hängen, ist in so einem Bergdorf gefangen, wird er eingeschneit oder so, dann ist ein Mordfall und dann muss man den lösen. Ja genau, ein Passwortessen, Bruder hat seinen Passwort in Richtung Café. Dann merkt man plötzlich, in Italien haben die ganz andere Kleidergrössen und das Outfit, das ich mir gekauft habe, ist einfach vier Nummern zu klein.
Komme ich trotzdem ein.
Die ganze Zeit so mit so einem Crop-Top so bauchfrei rum und dann bist du in so Kreisen plötzlich, wo es dir aber eigentlich ganz gut gefällt.
Und du merkst, ah, vielleicht that's my real me, Crop-Top.
Realo mio.
Realo mio. Oder, und das ist dann der Bogen, reala. Ja, genau. Und dann schliessen wir den Kreis und sind wieder zu Hause. Ja, aber warum denn nicht? Nee, aber warum denn nicht? Das ist ein guter Grund. Aber Schlafen ist ein Problem. Und ich finde Schlafen ein Riesenproblem. Ich finde, Schlaf ist eine der grossen Flüche der Menschheit. Die Menschheit wurde mehrmals verflucht in ihrer Existenz. Es sind Flut. Weg mit euch, weg mit den Riesen, weg mit dem ganzen Quatsch. Noah nochmal, Sisyphos auf jeden Fall. Aber das war sehr speziell. Das war primär jetzt auf einen Sisyphos. Eigentlich Sisyphus und du. Also das ist ja die einzigen, die explizit ... Im Grunde schon. Dann hatten wir die Heuschrecken, die ja bis heute noch ein Problem sind, wo auch ja die Bibel einerseits sagt, Gott hat alle Wesen erschaffen, aber ein Tier ist eine Plage. Also es gibt schon so eine leichte Hierarchie in der Bibel. Also er schuf alle Tiere, alle Vögel, alles im Wasser. Und Gott liebte alle Geschöpfe gleich. Aber wenn ich euch auf den Sack gehen will. Fange ich Heuschrecken, das ist eine Plage. Aber wenn ich euch bestrafen will, dann würde ich schon die Heuschrecke einsetzen. Also nicht das Eichhörnchen. Und die Heuschrecken so, sorry, warum sind wir, ich verstehe schon, dass viele von uns irgendwie erschreckend wirken können oder so, wir machen ja auch Geräusche und so, das ist ein bisschen nervig, verstehen wir? Aber ich merke, ihr seht schon selber ein paar Probleme. Wir seht ein paar Probleme, aber gut, Rhinocerosse, Leute, die haben Waffe auf der Nase, Stinktiere, ich ... Du hast ja das Statement begonnen mit mehreren Negativpunkten. Ich habe mir tot etwas gelernt, Sandwich-Taktik. Gibt jemandem was mein Problem? Lass mich das Statement direkt aus der Hand reißen und sagen, du hast ja ein paar gute Gründe genannt. Nein, pass auf, Gudo, das ist jetzt halt die erste Plage. Das ist das Wort schon wieder. Lass uns dieses Wort wieder. Es verletzt halt einfach. Ja, aber weißt du, ich weiss, ja, nee, gut, ihr seid jetzt die erste Plage. Plage! Alle müssen mal dran, alle müssen mal dran. Was ist denn mit der erste Welle? Schau mal, ich mag euch, ich mag euch. Das ist ein Wording-Problem. Ja, das ist auch richtig, ist ein Wording-Problem. Hebräisch ist halt leider sehr einschränkend, ne? Aber guck mal, das ist jetzt mal die erste Plage und das macht jetzt halt ihr. Die nächste Plage machen halt dann die Einhörner, die, die Rhinozeros. Die dritte Plage machen die Dinosaurier. So, kein Stress. So, ihr seid, betrachtet das mal so, ihr macht jetzt die erste Plage und dann seid ihr raus. Dann seid ihr erstmal raus, habt ihr Fehlren, dann seid ihr raus. Wegen dem Sinn. So, ja. Und, okay, aber Hand drauf, das ist noch andere Plagen. Hand drauf, überhaupt kein Problem. Habt ihr Hände? Was ist das denn überhaupt für ein ...
Ich meine, was ist ... Sorry, aber das ist auch mal ein Punkt. Das ist einfach so eine Säge als Hand. Du hast es gemacht. Das ist eine fucking Säge als Hand. Du hast es gemacht. Ja gut, aber es gibt ja auch ein bisschen Evolution, oder? Eine Sägenhand. Ja gut, aber ihr könnt ja auch ein bisschen in die Richtung tendieren. Jesus. Komm, also, komm, raus jetzt hier. Sie sind die eigentliche Plage. Und es gab nie wieder eine andere Plage. Nichts davon. Doch, Blut im Nien. Blutregen, Blut im Riel, Blut im Stuhl und Tränen überall. Aber auch nur bei Mads Mikkelsen, also wieder eine sehr spezielle Bestrafung. Und der Froschregen. Und da, glaube ich, wieder klassischer Holzweg. Der Frosch! Klassischer Holzweg. Jetzt bist du bei Magnolia, jetzt bist du bei Paul Thomas Anderson. Jetzt bist du vom Christentum abgewichen. Thomas Anderson. Jetzt bist du vom Christentum abgewichen, jetzt bist du in der Welt von Paul Thomas Anderson. Andersson schon, finde ich jetzt. Aber da führe ich mich erstens wohl und zweitens ist es ja eine biblische Plage. Nein, nein, es geht um ein Naturphänomen, das ist tatsächlich vollkommen. In Magnolia, dem Film von Paul Thomas Anderson, geht es ja um Zufälle und da war es tatsächlich so, dass irgendwo Frösche geregnet sind und niemand wusste, was los ist. Natürlich, viele Leute haben das religiös interpretiert und sind zum Judentum gewechselt und alles haben gesagt, raus hier aber schnell. Aber nicht ganz weit raus, sondern wir nehmen das Nächste. Genau, ja, ja. Die Bibel immer noch cool. Ja, ja, das immer noch. Eigentlich haben sie nur das Zweite Testament gestrichen. Jesus immer noch cool, ne, König der Juden, immer noch ganz gut. Weiß man nicht. So, aber es stellt sich raus, es war tatsächlich ein Wetterphänomen, dass es einen grossen Wirbelsturm gab, der über so ein Froschgebiet gezogen ist und einfach mal einfach alle Kröten und Frösche mitgesaugt hat. Und dann ist der Wirbelsturm weiterzogen über eine Stadt und dann sind ja alle runtergeregelt. Boah, stell dir vor, du bist in einem Froschgebiet. Ja, ja. Du hast eh schon nicht die beste Zeit deines Lebens. Wahrscheinlich nicht. Und dann bist du in einem Froschgebiet. Ja, ja, ja. Du musst ja da aktiv hingegangen sein. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass man kurz mal eine Ausfahrt an der A1 verpasst und plötzlich ist mal ein Froschgebiet, sondern du musst ja aktiv in ein Froschgebiet gehen, oder? Ich meine, es ist eine Plage. Ne, na, vielleicht auch eine Plage. Vier Dinge sind ja so fifty-fifty. Das ist auch so lustig. Du bist ja meinungsstark gewesen. Ja. Und das ist das meinungsstarkste, was man heutzutage bekommt, dass man so nach dreimal hin und her denkt, ja, vielleicht war es auch nicht so. Ich denke mir halt, es wäre nur ein sehr grosser Zufall, dass es es ist. Zum Beispiel, wir haben ja ein guter Punkt, weil wir haben eine Nachricht von einem Juristen bekommen. Wir haben sehr viele Nachrichten bekommen, die wir ignorieren. Die wir ignorieren. Manche kann man nicht ignorieren. Zum Thema Juristerei. Wir haben uns nämlich die Frage gestellt, ich habe ein Verbrechen begangen, ich habe geklaut, aber ich wollte das Verbrechen nicht begehen. Ich habe einen Weihnachtsbaum nicht bezahlt und das erst später gemerkt. Das heißt, im Moment der Tat hatte ich keine böse Absicht. Ich wollte nicht klauen und dann im Nachhinein war die Tat schon geschehen. Und da hat uns jemand aufgeklärt und er meinte, ja, du musst schon in dem Moment, in dem du eine Tat begehst, musst du sie auch wollen. Und er hat ein Beispiel gewählt, und zwar hat er gesagt, angenommen, ich würde dich umbringen wollen. Juristische Gehirnakrobatik, man kennt das. Sehr weit hergeholt jetzt. Jetzt kaufe ich mir eine Pistole und gehe in den Wald, um mit der Pistole schiessen zu üben. Und ich versuche da, ich stelle mir da eine Zielscheibe auf, die so aussieht wie Stefan. Und jetzt schiesse ich auf diese Zielscheibe um. Okay, weil das Detail verstehe ich überhaupt nicht, warum das so wichtig war für die Story. So, na ja, pass auf, es geht weiter. Wo kriegst du Zielscheiben auf dein Gesicht? Ich schiesse auf dein, na die gibt's, na die gibt's wirklich, die kannst du dir anfertigen lassen. Okay, schau mal hin. Also du kannst, du kannst... Ich meine, ist das nicht das Default? Ne, ne, wer ist. Ah, ich weiß gar nicht, was Default... Auch eine gute Frage, aber ich glaube, du kannst da PDFs hochladen und dann kriegst du so Zielscheiben. So, jetzt gehe ich in den Wald und schieße auf diese Zielscheibe, um meine ballistischen Fähigkeiten zu üben. Zufälligerweise gehst du am selben Abend in dem Wald joggen. Jetzt schiesse ich auf diese Zielscheibe, verfehle und treffe dich, den echten Stefan, und du bist tot. Jetzt kommt das Ganze vor Gericht und der Richter sagt, ja, sie wollten ja eigentlich Stefan Tietze umbringen, deswegen haben sie ja da diese Schiessübungen gemacht. Mein Anwalt sagt aber, ja, aber in dem Moment, in dem die Waffe abgefeuert wurde, wollte er das nicht. Er hatte zwar schon generell die Absicht, aber in der konkreten Tat hat sich das nicht verwirklicht, also kein Mord. Das wäre kein Mord? Das wäre kein Mord. Du hättest es dir anders überlegen können, das ist die Logik. Ja, ich wollte es in dem Moment quasi nicht, obwohl ich eigentlich, also eine abstrakte Absicht reicht nicht, du brauchst die konkrete Absicht in dem Moment.
Ich weiß, aber darunter liegt ja, du kannst es dir nochmal anders überlegen.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
So und so war das beim Baumarkt auch, dass ich in dem Moment, in dem ich den Erworben habe, den Weihnachtsbaum, wollte ich keinen begehen.
Ich bin es aber albern.
Geht bei Magnolia, springt jemand vom Dach. Genau, da ist es ja so, die Eltern streiten sich immer und der Vater zieht immer eine Shotgun und droht die Mutter zu erschießen. Die Shotgun ist aber nie geladen. Das heißt, es ist einfach deren toxische Beziehung Streitgedöns. Der Sohn hat keinen Bock mehr und lädt die Schrotflinte, ohne dass der Vater es weiss. Der Vater schiesst, ohne dass er versteht, dass er wirklich schiessen kann mit der ungeladenen Schrotflinte, die jetzt plötzlich geladen ist, verfehlt, schiesst zum Fenster raus.
In dem Moment fällt ein Fensterputzer genau an der ... Der Sohn.
Der Sohn, stimmt, der Sohn fällt runter.
Der Sohn, der sich umbringen, springt oben vom Dach, fliegt am Fenster vorbei und ihn trifft die Kugel. Ihn trifft die Kugel? Kein Suizid. Und darunter ist das Netz von einem Fensterputzer. Das heißt, er wäre gar nicht geschorben, sein Suizidversuch hätte fehlgeschlagen, wäre er nicht von der Kugel, die er selber geladen hat, erschossen worden. So, und jetzt die Frage ist das jetzt, ermordet er sich selbst, oder wie ist das, oder wer hat jetzt genau so und da ist auch wahrscheinlich die Sache, in dem Moment wollte der Vater den Sohn nicht ermorden, deswegen zählt das auch nicht. Ob es versucht, ermorden meine Mutter ist, ist das nicht ganz vergleichbar. Durch sehr viele Dinge ist es nicht vergleichbar, unter anderem, weil es nie eine Tötungsabsicht beim Vater gegenüber
des Sohnes gab. Und bei dir, der ja auch meine Pfanne schiesst im Wald, meine Pfanne. Ich dachte, meine Pfanne zum Gesicht? Das habe ich nie gehört. Doch, Ruhrgebiet. Ach, es ist wieder so ein Ruhrergut. Ich kann deine Pfanne nicht mehr sehen. ein weiterer Grund, dir den Chaos zu machen. Aber abstrakt, nicht konkret, ein abstrakter Tötungswunsch, kein konkreter. Ihr kriegt mich nicht, der fucking Obi-Bieber ist auf der Schliche, überall wo ich bin. Ich seh dich, ich weiss, dass ich beschattet werde vom Obi-Bieber. Ich seh dich überall, wo du da an den Bäumen rumknabberst, wenn ich mal wieder im Wald unterwegs bin. Ich seh dich. Ja, ich seh dich auch, du Lingo-Eule. Die ist mir auf den Fersen. Das ist ein wahrer Fluch, die Eulen, die Eulenfluch, das ist der wahre Fluch. Auf den Fersen, das verstehe ich auch nicht so ganz genau, örtlich. Ja, die Fersen sind ja hinten, ne? Wie, auf den Fersen, hinter den Fersen, an den Fersen. Klebt mir an den Fersen. Er klebt mir vor den Fersen. Wir haben sehr viele E-Mails bekommen. Also nicht nur für Florentins Service-Ecke. Richtig, Florentins Service-Ecke. Vielen Dank dafür, das ist ein toller Service. Wir werden darauf zurückkommen bei Zeiten. Genau, wir haben ganz viele, wir haben jetzt heute keine Zeit für. Leider nicht. In dieser speziellen Folge haben wir da keine Zeit für. Ich musste so lange bei McDonalds warten, da war der Service wieder so mittelmässig, deswegen keine Zeit, aber wir werden uns. Wir stellen die Fragen, die wir alle wissen wollen, wie verhält man sich richtig, um dem Servicepersonal möglichst wenig auf die Eier zu gehen. Weil man weiss ja manchmal gar nicht, was man falsch macht. Vielleicht hasst das Servicepersonal das, wenn man seine Jacke über den Stuhl beim Restaurant hängt, weil dann kommt man da nicht mehr vorbei und man selber nervt die und weiss es gar nicht. Oder ganz umgekehrt, vielleicht sind manche Sachen gar nicht so schlimm, wie uns der, die das Knigge weiss machen will. Ja. Und man mal ganz laut im Restaurant, weiß ich nicht, sich aufregen, auf den Tisch schauen oder so. Und es ist eigentlich total schön. Jeder Kunde hat einen Tischschlag, das ist okay. Darüber hinaus wird es unangenehm und unhöflich, aber man darf einmal, wo ist denn der Parmesan? Und niemand dreht sich um, weil alle wissen, na, das war sein Erster-Schlag, das ist in Ordnung, das ist prima. Genau, deswegen, das war spannend, da haben wir sehr viele Nachrichten bekommen, viele Bewerbungen bekommen, vielen Dank, die gucken wir uns alle an bei Zeiten. Es gibt auch, wir haben auch gelernt, dass es unfassbar viele unterschiedliche Servicebereiche gibt, es gibt natürlich so die, den grossen Überfaktor Lieferant von verschiedenen Sachen, von Pizza oder Einkäufen, Waren, dann gibt es natürlich Service, Gastronomie, aber auch Einkaufsladen und so, da gibt es wahnsinnig viele verschiedene Sachen.
Stewards.
Stewards, ja, man hat ja überall mit Menschen Kontakt, das stimmt, das ist ein Ding. Mir ist das aufgeregt, ich war letztens auf einem Event zum Thema Lieferung und Event Rocket Beans TV, Hamburg, Experian sind wir ab und zu unterwegs. Und dann gibt es da auch was zu essen. Wir sagen jetzt einfach Namen. Experian, X-Gamer XX. Und dann gibt es da Essen und es gab Pizza. Das ist ja nichts Ungewöhnliches, dass man dann so Pizza bereitstellt, so diese rechteckigen Pizzen, die dann so geschnitten sind für alle. Die klassische Familienpizza. Die Familienpizza. Die aus irgendeinem Grund die geometrische Form ändert. Die wahrscheinlich genauso gross ist wie der Ofengross ist. Also du kannst wahrscheinlich von der Familienpizza ableiten, wie gross der Ofen in der Pizzeria ist. Die konsequenterweise in runden Kartons geliefert werden müsste.
Ja, das ist kein schlechter Punkt. Wenn man mal ganz ehrlich ist. Wenn man ehrlich ist, bräuchte es das. Und dann schaue ich da hin, denke mir, ah, leckerer Pizza, schnabuliere ich mir rein, wie ein fettes Schwein, wie es sein muss. Und sehe da, ganz selbstverständlich, aufgebaut, neben den Pizzakartons, Pizzadip. Und dann dachte ich mir, sind wir jetzt wirklich an dem Punkt, wo das ganz selbstverständlich zur Pizza gereicht wird? Wir meinen Aioli sowas, ne? Aioli, Cocktail, mehrere verschiedene. Hat man auch nicht wirklich ablesen können, weil die farblich sehr ähnlich waren. Also der eine hat einen leichten Rotstich, der andere so einen leichten Blaustich, ob das dann so Camembert-Käse-Dipp ist oder sowas. Und ich merke das selber und ich habe das abgelehnt, ich habe Pizzaner bestellt als Purist, als napolitanischer Purist, habe aber immer wieder gesehen, dass einer in der Runde sich dann doch mal so einen Dip und dann dipt man da halt schon mal rein. Und mittlerweile bin ich, muss ich sagen, auch direkt angekommen, bei mir gehört der Dip mittlerweile dazu. Ja, ich habe Einreiseverbot in Italien, nicht nur wegen der Doku, sondern auch jetzt wegen dem Dip, das ist ein Problem.
Aber es gehört für mich wirklich, es ist kein Problem, gehört für mich mittlerweile dazu.
Und letztens habe ich sogar eine Pizza bestellt mit Dip und ich fand das so geil, weil dann kam die Lieferantin an und die hat dann so verschiedene Sachen, so hier ihre Cola und dann reicht sie mir den Dip und meinte, so hier ist ihr Salat und dann gibt sie mir die Pizza.
Und ich dachte mir, Moment, also denkt sie, das ist ein Salat in so einem winzigen Plastiktöpfen oder? Die wurde abgehört. So.
Sie wurde abgehört.
Weil auch die deutschen Pizzaizzabäcker müssen sich an die Regeln halten, die in Italien, aus Mailand, auch von Sizilien kommen, Palermo sagt, so und so habt ihr das zu machen, es gibt keine Pizza Hawaii, es gibt keinen Pizzadip. Oh, ich verstehe. Sie hat, wenn du geguckt hättest, unter ihr Jacke, Mikrofon an und sie hat gesagt, hier ist ihr Salat.
Wissend, wenn ich ihr den Pizzadip gebe, dann hat sie einen Pferdekopf.
Verstehe, das wird sozusagen aus Diskretgründen anders behandelt.
Wenn du dann Pizzadip bestellst, im System ist es ein Salat und dann so, ah, hier sind die Salate oder so. Wenn du ein Sextoll bestellst, ist es ein Blumenstrauss und dann auch so, ah, Blumenstrauss, hier die Blumenstrauss und alles mögliche. Das heißt, okay, verstehe, ich dachte im Moment, es ist wirklich so ein, entweder es ist ein guter Gag, weil Pizza dem ist ja das ungesundeste, was man überhaupt essen kann, Salat wäre das Gegenteil, also ah, hier Salat, so, aber es war gar kein humoriger, lustig Moment dabei. Also entweder sie war so abgebrüht, dass sie diese Gags so wechselt. Auch weil du wieder so verweinend die Tür aufgemacht hast. Also es ist gar kein humoriger Moment. Nee, weil ich wirklich lange auf die Pizza warten musste. Und irgendwann kommt dir dieser streckliche Moment, wo du denkst, die kommt nicht mehr. Wo du von einer enttäuschten Hoffnung zu einer Verzweiflung übergehst, wo du von einem, okay, ich muss lange warten zu, die kommt nicht mehr, die ist vorbei, das war's, so, die ruft nicht mehr zurück. Das war's. Das war's, das ist Ende. Das kann man nichts machen. Und ich würde dann auch nichts weiter tun. Nee, nee, dann geht man ruhig ins Bett und dann guckt man, man wartet aber noch insgeheim noch ein paar Tage weiter. Genau, ob nach vier Tagen der Lieferant noch wirklich mit zu essen und Moos in den Haaren so, sie wissen, ich glaube nicht, was ich erlebt habe. Hier, ihre Pizza, ich habe sie nicht gegessen. Ich habe noch und ich habe noch gewartet. Ja, genau, du hast noch gewartet. Und das fand ich ganz gut. Aber wie siehst du das? Also ist für dich der Pizzadip mittlerweile angekommen? Ist das eine Frivolität, die wir jetzt akzeptieren in unserer Mitte?
Also ich war Hardliner, seit meines Lebens war ich Hardliner.
Kein, ich habe einmal mit einem Franzosen gesprochen, der meinte, keine Eiswürfel im Wein, das ist ein Affront.
Da habe ich gesagt, was?
Naja, aber also dann habe ich natürlich gesagt, immer wenn ich Leute gesehen habe, die sich Eiswürfel in den Beinen gemacht haben, haben, gesagt, ah, das macht man ja gar nicht und so, ne, das ist Bullshit, das ist alles dieses aufgesetzte Kack, jeder soll das bitte genau so machen, wie er da sich Bock hat. Ich bin da, auch Rotwein zu Fisch, ja, Pizza Hawaii, wenn du smarts, ja. Du, wir werden ja aufgelgelaut von Franzosen, die haben überall ihre Leute. Wenn du Bock hast auf Pizzadip, weil du sonst den trockenen Rand, der ja oft viel zu trocken ist, sonst nicht essen kannst, bitte, help yourself. Steak mit Ketchup? Hau rein! Ketchup auf Pizza? Wenn du's mag. Sushi mit Ketchup? Hau rein! Rein da, du bist wirklich komplett offen! Inzwischen denke ich mir ja, wie es dir schmeckt. Ja, bitte, bitte, help yourself! Das heisst, wenn du einlädst und du machst ein richtig herrliches Risotto, du machst einen schönen Karpfen, alles perfekt und ich komme, sitze am Tisch und sage, sag mal, hast du Curry-Ketchup da? Ja, und das ist lustigerweise, sprichst du etwas an, was tatsächlich im Politikum bei mir im Privatleben ist. Ich sag mal, also es ist kein Scherz, aber ich habe schon manchmal den Gewürz-Ketchup, der immer wieder neu gekauft wird, für mich in meinen Kühlschrank gestellt wird, den habe ich schon oft versteckt. Und so getan, als hättest du keinen, weil deine Gäste gesagt haben, ja, wirklich herrlich, herrlich, wild, lang. Ein Gast hat so meine tollen Steaks, die ich dann auf meinem Smoker acht Stunden lang draußen, nein, aber ich habe die, ich habe so ein gutes Stück Fleisch zum Beispiel mal gekauft, das dann auf dem Grill gemacht und mich da sehr drüber gefreut, da habe ich so fein geschnitten, Leute haben Salat und dann hab ich das so auf den Tisch und es sah richtig schön aus. Und dann wurde ein Gewürzketchup rausgeholt und er lost my shit. Aus dem Halfter an der Hälfte einfach. Ja, und das ist halt eskaliert. Okay, aber da scheint eine Grenze der Toleranz bei dir erreicht zu sein, wenn es um dein eigenes Essen geht. Ja, wenn nicht Leuten das, ja, okay, vielleicht muss man das alles nochmal aufweichen und sagen, ich finde, dass die Leute, die es dir machen, das Essen, schon ein Wörtchen mitzureden haben, dass zumindest es mal zunächst probiert wird. Weil das ist ja oft, es kommt ja dieses Gewürz-Ketchup-Move, schon bevor irgendeine Gabel im Mund war. Weißt du? Ja, Moment, aber ist das nicht noch beleidigender, wenn jemand dein Essen isst und sagt, nee, da muss Ketchup drauf. Also da will ich doch lieber jemanden haben, der sagt, ich esse einfach überall Curry-Ketchup mit, unabhängig von der Qualität. So eine Abomination. Aber ist Gewürz-Ketchup und Curry-Ketchup das gleiche? Können wir das kurz erklären? Ja, ich glaube Gewürzketzup.
Das ist dieser, dieser rote, dunkle, rote Stange. Oder wie heißt diese Marken? Heeler, ja. Ja, Heeler Gewürzketzup. Genau, der einfach jeder Koch irgendwie, wenn man schon sieht, diese Form in der Tasche, weiss man sofort, okay, das wird ein harter Abend für mich. Ja, ich war, ja, ich war neulich in der Oper und da habe ich gerade die Wahlküre gesehen und da war bei Hunding zuhause im ersten Akt stand so ein Heeler Gewürzketschup auf dem Tisch und das fand ich ein sehr lustiges, inszenatorisches Detail, weil ich dachte, ja, Hunding ist so ein Typ und direkt, ich habe noch nie so viel geweint in dieser Oper, weil ich, der Hass aufing war so klar mit dieser Heeler-Gewürz-Ketchup. Und ich war noch nie so, Oper hat mich noch nie so emotional berührt. Ja, werden zukünftige Generationen das verstehen, was der Heeler-Gewürz-Ketchup heute für uns ist? Ich hoffe nicht, ich hoffe, das steht aus, ich hoffe, man sollte mal das Werk in Brand stecken. Oder? Nein, ein Froschregen würde Heeler vielleicht auch. Okay, mit Froschgeschmack in Zukunft. Vielleicht ist es dadurch nicht besser. Ist ja natürlich Franzosen, würdest du da Frosch mit Gewürzketchup, da glaube ich, fliegst du raus. Da bist du sofort raus. Ja, genau. Ich wollte zu dem Thema Pizzadip, denn ich habe nämlich auch mal da ein wenig nachgeforscht. Und zwar gibt es ja immer so, man unterstellt ja Kulturen manchmal Ansprüche, die die gar nicht haben. Purismus. Man denkt so, ja na ja, um Gott, der echte Italiener würde nie, da muss man den trockenen Rand essen und dabei die Nationalhunde singen, nein, niemals. Und da habe ich mir ein Video angeguckt, genau zu dem Thema, und da meinte ein Italiener, es ist in Italien vollkommen gängig, dass man die Ränder mit Olivenöl isst. Dass du noch so ein kleines Schälchen Olivenöl hast und dass du den Pizzarand noch mal so in Olivenöl dippst. Und ja, okay, das ist jetzt zwar kein Cocktail-Dressing, aber die Grundidee ist da, dass auch Italiener gemerkt haben, die Pizza ist wirklich perfekt, das vielleicht erfolgreichste Gericht der Menschheitsgeschichte, aber der Rand ist leider immer ein Problem, der Griff, der mitgegessen werden kann und in Italien ist es üblich, da so Olivenöl, vielleicht mit Salz auch ein bisschen, dass man das so ein bisschen dann auch wegschnappet. Da kriegt niemand Hunger. Und ein Bier, ein Bier Der Zettel zur Pizza ist tatsächlich üblicher, viel üblicher als den Rotwein, den Primitivo rauszuholen. Okay, also ich will nur sagen, dass man da vielleicht mal aufeinander zugehen muss und wirklich mal sagen kann, dass die Botschafter einberufen werden und man sagt Aufeinander zugehen, voll einander lernen, Pizza Hawaii lecker. Das ist auch so ein freies Thema. Vielleicht interessiert es Italiener gar nicht Pizza Hawaii oder so, aber man spielt natürlich auch gerne mit diesen Klischees und mit diesen Ansprüchen, die man ja auch spielerisch umsetzen kann. Ja, wir sind noch immer in der Service-Ecke. Wir müssen nämlich eine allseits beliebte Rubrik aufmachen, wie das Podcast-UFO Entschuldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung, Uldigung! Denn ich habe Quatsch erzählt, also beziehungsweise ich habe meinen Kumpel zitiert, der Restaurant-Gastro-Chef, also Service-Chef ist. Ah, mit dem Trinkgeld, dass man gar kein Trinkgeld geben soll. Und er hat die Stellthese rausgehauen, dass er mit so fünf Euro pro Tisch irgendwie, also die fünf Euro aufgerunden, happy wäre und nicht wie ich, der immer zehn Prozent gibt, alle anderen eigentlich auch, die gelernt haben, zehn Prozent, egal wie hoch die Rechnung ist, zehn Prozent, nicht irgendwie einfach aufrunden. Was natürlich, wenn man mit mehreren Leuten isst, schon zu viel Trinkgeld führen kann, weil er meinte, das erwartet er gar nicht. Da kamen ein paar Nachrichten an und ich möchte das revidieren, mein weirder, weirder, weirder Freund hat Bullshit erzählt, darauf nochmal angesprochen, hat er auch was ganz anderes, also das ist auf jeden Fall eine Stimme, die man vielleicht nicht mehr konsultieren sollte für dieses Thema. Die vielleicht auch gar nicht diesen beruflichen Hintergrund hat, weil um ehrlich zu sein, wenn man sich die Bude mal anguckt, wo der wohnt, also wirklich, ob der ein Gastronomiechef ist, das weiss man nicht genau. Es ist Uwe, es ist einfach Uwe. Fragezeichen als Ausrufezeit. Als Zinrufezeichen. Auf jeden Fall da jetzt, deswegen nehme ich das komplett zurück, also ignoriere das einfach komplett, streiche das im Kopf. Und für die entstandenen Schaden möchte ich mich entschuldigen. Wir haben das Podcast Uwe Fonds eingerichtet. Ja, für die Entschuldigungen, ja. Für die Entschuldigung. Und die angerichteten Schäden. Da sind jetzt schon, ich ich glaube 12 Euro drin. Ja, das war mal mehr. Wir haben das leider etwas ungünstig investiert zur aktuellen Weltlage. Weil ich, genau, wir haben es irgendwie falsch angelegt. The Rock Pull ist ein Begriff, der oft genutzt wird und uns wurde der Teppich unter den Beinen weggezogen und seitdem liegen wir auf dem Rücken. Finanziell, was das angeht. Wir liegen wie so ein Käfer auf dem Rücken. Panzer, auf dem Schittin-Panzer und können uns wackeln und zappeln und können uns nicht bewegen, leider. Mit der grossen Frage, was eigentlich Schittin genau ist. Niemand weiss es. Ist es das gleiche wie Fingernägel? Und ist es das gleiche, was in Tonic Water drin ist? Viele, viele offene Fragen, aber wir werden uns diesem Service-Thema mal genau annehmen, wenn es dann in die Florentin-Service-Ecke geht. Ich übernehme da vollste Verantwortung auch für dieses Format. Das wollte mich fragen, weil da steht ja ganz gross Florentin-Service-Ecke drauf, ob du dann jetzt wenigstens die Verantwortung übernimmst für meinen Bullshit. Wenn wir gerade ohnehin schon in der Uldigungsrubrik sind, möchte ich auch noch etwas ansprechen, was mich die letzten Wochen intensiv beschäftigt hat, nämlich Lego Bionicle.
Das war mit der schlimmste Shitstorm, den wir jemals bekommen haben. Wir haben schon über viele Dinge in diesem Podcast geredet, über auch verschiedene Menschheitsverbrechen, über unsere eigenen Probleme. Und selten kriegen wir so viele Nachrichten, als wenn wir über Lego Bionicle reden. Ich habe viele Fehler begangen, ich habe dort viel Müll geredet, ich habe vieles in meinem Kopf vermischt, vergessen, verwischt, ersetzt durch andere Franchises. Das ist ausgedacht. Ein wilder Fruchtsalat, der improvisiert in dem Moment leider ungenießbar wurde. Und ich habe dazu ein Statement verfasst auf Reddit, das könnt ihr euch in Ruhe durchlesen, da habe ich alles nochmal aufgeklärt, alle Fehler habe ich versucht zu korrigieren mit Anschlussquellen und auch hier habe ich aus dem Podcast-Ufer-Entschuldigungsfonds habe ich fünf Euro gespendet an die Bionicle-Hilfe, die dort versucht, sich einzusetzen für Aufklärung und dort auch Entwicklungshilfe leistet. Also das ist ein ernstes Thema, es tut mir leid, dass ich das so auf die leichte Schulter genommen habe und das verwechselt habe mit vielen anderen Dingen. Es tut mir wirklich leid. Entschuldigung. Die Bionicle, wo genau erzählt wird, also genau der Aufklärungsarbeit, wo sehr viele Menschen sehr viel Zeit ihres Lebens opfern, um Aufklärungsarbeit zu leisten, damit wirklich allen klar ist, woher kommen Bionicle, für wen setzen sie sich ein. Welche Probleme haben haben sie? Bionicle werden natürlich auch oft als Helden verehrt, klar, Matanui, aber sie haben natürlich auch Probleme. Was steckt hinter der Maske quasi, sinnbildlich? Was steckt hinter der Maske? Manche Masken wurden ja verflucht. Nicht zum Legotechnik-Teil. Genau, und da setzen die sich wirklich Tag und Nacht ruhelos ein für die Ansprüche von Bionicle, dass die in unserer Gesellschaft auch gehört werden. Ja, und ich bin auch selber zu Schaden gekommen bei der ganzen Sache, weil du mir gesagt hast, dass mein grüner Lego Slicer ein Bionicle ist. Richtig, es ist ein Slicer. Es gab vor Bionicles Slicer, die leider oft vergessen werden in unserer Gesellschaft, denn alle schauen nur auf die heldenhaften Bionicle. Nein, es gab davor das Vorgängerprodukt Slicer, die auch schon diese Plastikscheibenkatapulte hatten. Wie auch schon? Haben Bionicle die auch? Bionicle haben die erst mal nicht, haben sie später, aber doch bekommen, vor allem in den Kleintor. Und da wurde sozusagen Slicer ins Bionicle-Ranchise? Es wurde reingeschleißt, ja, da gibt es schon eine Verbindung, das ist lore-technisch nicht ganz sauber gelöst, muss man sagen, das wird eher totgeschrieben. Ja, das ist auch die einzige Lore, Ungereimtheit. Ja, ansonsten ist das wirklich felsenfest, komplett wasserdicht gezogen, da machst du nichts falsch. Felsenfest, wasserdicht. Genau. Super. Ja, wobei in Felsen ja auch oft Wasser drin ist, da musst du aufpassen. Leider, ich mag das gar nicht. Echt nicht drin. Also wie viel Wasser ist in so einem Berg, ist auch mal eine spannende Angelegenheit. Wird der trockener, je tiefer es in den Berg geht, oder wird der feuchter, je tiefer es in den Berg geht? Das macht mich irre wütend, dieses Thema, weil Wasser gehört ins Meer oder ins Sehen, meinetwegen. Macht mich auch sauer.
Aber es hat den Berg nichts verloren.
Was suchst du da?
Es macht mich rasend und da muss ich auch ein bisschen auf mich jetzt achten.
Und ich habe mit Bluthochdruck zu kämpfen, tatsächlich.
Und wenn es so wieder mit dieser Wasser-in-Berg-Thematik ankommt, das ist für mich wie der Mond, den man tagsüber sieht.
Dinge haben vergessen, wo ihr Platz ist. Ja, das stimmt. Man muss wieder mal eingreifen. Also du sagst, es braucht eine Neuordnung.
Die Elefante sind zu sehr vermischt. Feuer, Wasser, Luft, Wasser, also was ist Luftfeuchtigkeit eigentlich? Luftfeuchtigkeit eigentlich? Ich habe ja letztens erzählt, ich habe einen Hydrometer, mit dem man die Luftfeuchtigkeit... Genau, auch wir ganz viele Leute … Das heißt Hygrometer. Hörst du wieder falsch gesagt. Die Leute haben gesagt, du hast Hygrometer gesagt, das heißt, es ist ein Hydrometer, also deswegen sage ich Hydrometer. Nein, du hast Hydrometer gesagt und es ist ein Hygrometer. Aber es heißt doch Hydraulik. Ja. Das ist doch auch Wasser. Ich weiß auch nicht warum. Turtok, Level 36, welche Attacke lernt der? Hygro-Waffe. Hydro-Pumpe. Hydro ist Wasser. Ich weiß, dass es Wasser ist. Ja. Aber es geht ja nicht um Wasser, sondern es geht um die Luftfeuchtigkeit. Und wenn der sich da ein G-etymologisch reingeschlichen hat, dann weiß ich nicht, woher es kommt. Wenn man diesen Feinunterschied mit G ausdrücken will, dann soll das doch auch erlaubt sein. So, also, ich habe einen Hydrometer. Again, ich glaube das nicht. Kannst du kurz googeln? Die Leute haben gesagt, ich soll Hydrometer sein. Hygro! So, ist ja Quatsch, kein Mensch kennt Hygro. Ich weiß. Das ist genau wie wir in der komplette Folge über introvertiert gesprochen haben. Ja, ich weiß. Und sich da jemand gemeldet hat, es heisst eigentlich introvertiert. Nein, heisst es nicht. Heisst es einfach nicht. So, Punkt. Also, ich habe einen Hydrometer mit Luftfeuchtigkeit und ich habe es mir zur Aufgabe gemacht, das so feucht zu machen, wie es geht. Ich versuche, meinen Atem ganz feucht zu machen und dann hauche ich auf dieses Hydrometer und ich habe es schon auf 99 % gekriegt. Aber diesen letzten einen Prozent, 100 % Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Hauchst du es an?
Ich hauche es an, ich haue es auf den Rezeptor.
Du hast es jetzt wie so ein Dampfbad, so ein Hamam.
Ich bin bereit, alles zu tun, um dieses Hydrometer auf 100 % Luftfeuchtigkeit zu kriegen.
Ich will wissen, was 100 % Luftfeuchtigkeit ist.
Klar, hat auch mit der Temperatur zu tun, ne, warme Luft kann mehr Feuchtigkeit aufnehmen als kalt und so weiter. Aber das ist für mich jetzt mein aktuelles Ziel. Es ist ja wie in Hitlers Germania, wo dann diese grosse Kuppel gebaut werden sollte. Ja. Welthauptstadt Germania. Linz oder was? Wo war das? War es nicht Linz? Berlin. Berlin, okay. Und da sollte diese Riesenkuppel entstehen, in der es tatsächlich hätte regnen können. Wow. Diese Kuppel hatte Platz für 300.000 Menschen und da wäre ein eigenes Mikroklima drin gewesen, weil die so gross geworden wäre. Vermutlich gar nicht umsetzbar, die Pläne von Albert, aber tatsächlich hätte es da wahrscheinlich Wolken und Regen geben können. Krass. Okay, das ist wiederum cool. Und dann gibt es eigene Tiere, die nur da leben. Genau es ein Biotop ist, was nur für die richtig ist. Kuppeltiere. Kuppelotter ist entstanden. Die können nur da wohnen. Und plötzlich hat sich in Blitzevolutionen, Blitzkrieg-Evolutionen hat sich dann Otter herausgearbeitet, der dann da lebt. Kuppelotter. Ja, ein Kuppelotter. Sprich fliessendolch. Und die kannst du ja nicht auswildern, ne? Weil die kannst du ja nicht auswildern. Die können ja nicht woandersleben. Können wir nicht woanders überleben. Ja, aber da bin ich aktuell dran. Am Thema Luftfeuchtigkeit ist immer noch ein faszinierendes Thema, wenn man es ja nicht sieht. Sag mir Bescheid, wenn du 101 Prozent Luftfeuchtigkeit hast. Ja. Nee, du lachst. Ja, übersättigt. Du lachst dich kaputt. Aber Trumps Stölle sind über 100 Prozent. Ja, das stimmt. Du kriegst dann wieder was zurück. There's no rules. Wenn du 105 Prozent Zoll machst, dann kriegst du ja, also musst du ja was abgeben quasi. Das geht dann wieder einmal im Kreis rum. Wir äußern uns normalerweise nicht zu tagesaktuellen politischen Dingen, aber wir müssen uns ansprechen. Wer diese Folge hört, ist dann schon Konklave oder schon gewesen oder wird es Konklave sein? Aber ich freue mich tatsächlich all auf Konklave. Ich finde es eine fucking geile Veranstaltung. Tut mir leid, falls ihr es jetzt hier so erfahren müsstet, aber der Papst ist tot. Todesursache unklar, kurz nach dem Ostersägen und dann ist ja bei jedem Papst, das liess eine Verstörungstheorie raus, dann aus jedem Papst, ich überlege immer so, wenn der stirbt, denke ich mir, wartet erst mal drei Tage ab. Wir haben im Christentum mittlerweile gelernt, erst mal Entspannung, erst mal locker. Also nachdem Jesus ja gestorben ist und drei Tage nach. Du hast recht, man hat nicht gelernt. Man hat überhaupt nichts gelernt. Bei keinem Tod sagt man, warte mal, erst mal, locker, locker, locker, jetzt Beerdigung. Die Beerdigung ist erstmal recht kostspielig, lass uns das erstmal hinten anstellen und erstmal drei Tage warten. Du hast völlig recht, eigentlich ist es ja wieder der Religionsidee, der eine Gottes Sohn ist für die... Ja, aber der ist ja auch Nachfolger, der Papst ist ja auch schon so ein bisschen wie Jesus, so ein bisschen, dass er da so... Stellvertreter Christi am Erden. Ja, genau, Stellvertreter, gut, aber manche Kräfte sind ja auch übergeleitet so. Das heißt, das wäre halt geil, wenn ein Papst mal irgendwie nach drei Tagen, allein so Gehirntot für drei Tage und dann kommt er wieder aus dem Koma nach drei Tagen oder irgendwie sowas, wird es ja irgendwann mal geben. Das ist dann geil. Also warte ich drei Tage ab, immer noch tot. Aber stattdessen macht man ja alles, um an dem Todeszeitpunkt werden Glocken geläutet, um das Volk zu unterrichten, es wird der Ring durchschlagen, also es wird quasi das Gegenteil gemacht von Abwart. Genau. Es wird sehr, sehr viel gemacht. Anders als zum Beispiel bei, keine Ahnung, wenn Leute in Deutschland sterben, egal wer jetzt kein krasses Amt oder so, einfach Privatmenschen, wird weniger unternommen als bei dem Oberhaupt der Kirche, wo man ja am ehesten noch erwarten könnte, dass er vielleicht aufersteht am dritten Tag und sagt, there I am. Ist er dann eigentlich dann immer noch so alt? Ist er immer noch Papst, wird den neuen Papst gewählt? Und ist er dann immer noch so alt und so krank? Oder also, weil... Ne, ist Baby, Neugeborenes. Er würde für eine Neuge... Moment, das ist ja eine andere Religion, Reinkarnation, du meinst, dass er irgendwo geboren wird. Geist-Baby, entsprechendes Geist-Baby, was so spricht, wie er am Ende gesprochen hat. Kann man das sehen? Ja. Okay, ja, Geister, okay, ist ein sichtbarer Geist. Ja. Und das Baby ist nackt oder hat das Kleidung wie ein Papst? Okay, sorry, ich kenne die Regeln nicht. Sorry, ja, okay, gut, ja, nur weil du einmal Bibelkurs gemacht hast, weil du das Hörbuch von Rufus Beck angehört hast, bist du jetzt der Christenexpert oder was, bist du da tief drin? Ja. Ja, okay, ja, sorry, ich bin halt nicht so drin. Jesus. Meine Güte. So, und jetzt kommt endlich mal ein junger Papst, mal endlich mal ein junger Papst, mal so 16, 17 oder so, so ein Breakdance-Papst, wo man einfach sagt, wir committen uns mal auf 70 Jahre Papst. Gen Z-Papst. Gen Z-Papst. Ja, ich, ähm, ja, mir tat schon leid, ich mochte Papst Franziskus trotz vieler Unzulänglichkeiten auch schon sehr. Ja, was sind deine Top-5-Unzulänglichkeiten des toten Papstes? Er war nicht so gut im Fußball. Ja, das stimmt. Also da haben wir dann draußen gekippt. Vor allem die Freistösse waren halt echt eine Katastrophe. Er wollte immer einen Freistoss, ne? Er hat auch viele Freistoss rausgeholt, ne? Ich weiß, sein Freistoss selbstbewusst sein war jetzt, er hat die rausgeholt. Genau, in grossen Differenz, er hat die mega rausgeholt, aber er wollte sie dann auch immer selber schiessen. Und da sage ich, nee, Franz, so funktioniert es nicht. Nee, und dann haben wir da hinten immer, weißt du, Castel-Gandolf, haben wir da so rumgekickt ein bisschen. Ja, ja, ja. Und das war nicht so sehr viel Stärke. Also Unzündigkeit Nummer eins. Ja.ündigkeit Nummer zwei, die Arabiater waren immer ein bisschen zu, nicht al dente mehr, das war schon ein bisschen, das war schon so ein Schlonsfest. Das war einfach weich. Für mich auch ein grosses Problem, oft Kleidung falschrum angezogen. Nervt. Ich habe es ein paar Mal erklärt, ich habe gesagt, pass auf, hier ist oben, hier ist unten und er immer, oh, scusi, scusati, scusati und so. Und da denke ich mir, irgendwann muss das doch auch checken, irgendwie sowas. Ja, man weiss die halbe Bibel auswendig und kann die Robe nicht richtig rum anziehen. Nee, ich meine, er hat nicht alles, was er gemacht hat, war so toll. Nee, das stimmt. Aber vieles war dann trotzdem auch toll. Wie zum Beispiel? Er hat sich ja für den Frieden eingesetzt. Weil sein Tierarzt ist super on point. Ja. Ja, das ist gar nicht so leicht. Du hast ja eine gewisse Wässrigkeit mit dem Kaffee und dem Biskuit. Das musst du ja hinkriegen, dass es saftig, aber nicht so wässrig ist. Absolut fantastisch. No Notas. No Notas. Aber man muss jetzt sagen, No Lens Volens, das Kapitel ist vorbei. Und jetzt, ja, ich freue mich sehr auf das Konklave, weil ich bin ein Riesenfan dieser Tradition, die jetzt so reinkicken. Grosser Fan auch des Films gewesen. Ja, das passt natürlich überraschend gut. Gruselig gut. Wir gucken dich an. Wir gucken dich an Ralph Fiennes. We don't name names, aber wir gucken dich an, Edward Berger und Ralph Fiennes.
Die werden ja eingesperrt.
Und ich habe mal gehört, ich habe tatsächlich ein Video gesehen zum Konklave, dass es irgendwann mal ein Konklave gab, wo die nicht zu Pötte kamen.
Die haben immer nicht richtig abgestimmt, sodass ein Papst gewählt wurde.
Da haben die noch nicht in Rom abgestimmt, sondern in einer Kleinstadt. Und da haben die dann alle gut gewohnt und wurden auch fürstlich bezahlt in ihren Mietwohnungen. Und haben auch das Gehalt vom Papst bekommen. Und haben richtig gut verdient, haben richtig gut gegessen und haben gesagt, pass mal auf, warum soll sich hier was ändern? Ist das nicht das paradiesische Zustände? Und dann haben die gesagt, nee, das passt nicht geändert. Und jetzt sind die nur noch ein paar Tage in der Konklave und kriegen jeden Tag schlechteres Essen, sodass die wirklich einfach gezwungen werden, irgendwann fähig zu werden, was ich mir gut finde. Würde ich auch einführen bei jedem Meeting oder sowas wirklich, dass die Snacks immer schlechter werden, je länger es dauert. Ich frag mich nur. Ich meine, aber ganz kurzer Einstischenschlup, das Konklave vor drei Paläten, ich meine das von Johannes Paul II. war sogar noch, dass sie da nicht raus konnten. Ah, das kann sein. Die waren komplett drin, in der sexilischen Kapelle die ganze Zeit. Da gibt es ja dann den Spruch Extra Omnes, es wird zugemacht, ausserhalb von allen alle raus und sie machen da ihren Scheiss. Konklave heisst ja auch mit Schlüssel. Ja. Du bist ja dran. Genau, so. Und ich frage mich halt, also angenommen, du bist jetzt der Koch im Vatikan, du bist wahrscheinlich Israel der krassesten Köche, die das gibt oder halt so bescheiden, keine Ahnung, weiss ich nicht. Und dann sagt er, okay, pass auf, du hast jetzt ein Menü, fünf Tage, mega gutes Essen am ersten Tag, etwas schlechteres Essen am zweiten Tag, ist, finde ich, eine Herausforderung, weil du musst ja erstmal wissen, wo lande ich, was ist mein Ground Zero Essen, was ist das schlechtest mögliche Essen, das man jemandem geben kann, also was ist das dann, was ist das schlechteste Essen der Welt? Wieder aufgewärmte Kartoffeln sind auf jeden Fall ein Strong Contender, finde ich. Ja, oder so wirklich kalte Hafer schleimen oder einfach so auf den Teller spucken oder so. Ich weiß nicht, wie weit man dann wirklich geht. Wie man es treiben. Also wenn man wirklich sagt, man gibt einfach einen Beutel Gras oder so, wie schlecht geht's. Und dann musst du ja wirklich die Abstufung hinkriegen als Koch, zu sagen, erster Tag, klar, Pizza. So, erster Tag, erst mal Pizza-Party für die Pstwahl, so, das Papstpizza. Papstpizza, Papstpizza, das ist klar. Dann zweiter Tag, vielleicht so Fisch oder so, keine Ahnung, dann geht's abwärts. Und was ist dann das schlechteste Essen? Ich finde, das ist eine Herausforderung. Ja, es ist definitiv eine Herausforderung. Also, ja, mega. Alles darum ist toll. Ja. Und dann wäh den Papst. Und dann, ja, es gab tolle Geschichten, also, und so weirde Geheimnisse und dann auch diese Störsender, die in der Sexischen Kapelle verbaut sind. Damit die ja nicht abgehört werden. Damit die nicht abgehört und selber auch nichts empfangen können, also die haben keinen Kontakt zur Außenwelt. Das ist schon alles ziemlich, ziemlich cool. Aber Jahre ging es ja dann doch immer relativ schnell, muss man sagen. Ja, muss man leider sagen. Also er war dann nach zwei Tagen wurde dann … Die waren beim Burger und haben gesagt so, aber tiefer steigen wir nicht ab und jetzt gehen wir wieder raus. Und Benedikt XVI. Ratzinger, natürlich auch spannend, war ja der Vorsitzende, war Kardinals Dekan, also der Vorsitzende, er hat das Konklave geschmissen, also so ein bisschen the most boring decision, überhaupt, den einfach zu nehmen. Ach Moment, als er abgetreten ist, oder? Ach so. Nein, er war der, als er damals gewählt wurde in seinem Konklave, der Konklave-Vorsitzende der Dekan. Und als er sich in Papstet hat, war er dann gar nicht ganz komplett raus aus allem. Lebt er noch? Nein, ne. Ist 95 geworden.
Er dachte eigentlich, dass er gar nicht, dass er noch ein Jahr lebt, nach dem, nach dem Abtreten. Und dann hat er noch sehr lange gelebt. Auch spannend. Der hätte aber nicht nochmal ein Comeback machen können. Das weiß ich nicht. Das wäre ja jetzt sein Comeback. Jetzt ist er leider schon tot. Ist er leider schon tot. tot. Das ist aber dann, was ich sehr spannend finde, Namen. Du kannst dir ja den Namen aussuchen, mit dem du dann jetzt immer angesprochen wirst. Genau. Das ist ja etwas sehr, sehr Neu-, also Einzigartiges auf der Welt, dass du dir einfach so Namen gibst. Ja, oder du wirst Künstler, Indie-Künstler oder so. Der heißt nicht hess nicht Marc Medlock, das ist Künstlername. Medlock der Erste. Der hess doch nicht Medlock, oder? Wer ist denn Medlock? Wer ist Marc Medlock? Wer ist Marc Medlock? So lustig ist deine Referenzen, Promi-Referenzen sind so eine ganz kleine Gruppe von so … Von so einem Stefan-Raab-Gesangswettbewerb. Ja. So Lena … Lena Bellantruth, Mark Medlock, also oft Gesangswettbewerbe, alles so spielt so 2010. Ja, das war meine Hochzeit, da habe ich wirklich viel konsumiert. Und da hast du auch aufgehört, Popkultur, also so diese Art … Seitdem wurde es nie wieder besser. Ja, okay. Wund es nicht mehr besser. Hast du einen Favoriten für einen Papst?
Also bist du, hast du Bock?
Äh, Pizzabella.
Pizzabella, ja, ist witzig, klingt lustig.
Finde ich lustig, finde ich cool.
Und der erste Papst, der nicht seinen Namen ändert.
Oder nur Pizzabello.
Einfach sagt Pizzabello.
Pizzabello.
Es ist ja so, ich bin ja ein großer Fan der Serie The Young Pope,
Paolo Solentino mit Jude Law, der einen relativ jungen Papst spielt und Naja, es ist schon The Young Pope und nicht The Relatively Young Pope. Okay, gut, ähm, okay, er ist jung. So, und der nennt sich ja der Dreizehnte. Pius der Dreizehnte. Umstrittener Name, allein deswegen wird glaube ich nie erzählt in der Serie, weil Papst Pius der Zwöl. vorhergesagt hat, dass der Papst Pius XIII. der letzte Papst sein wird. Geil. Danach gibt es nie wieder einen so Armageddon oder das war's, alles bricht zusammen, Kirche ist vorbei. Und deswegen nennt sich niemand Pius XIII. aus Angst vor dieser Wahrsagung. Prophezeiung, aber hat sich sonst jemand schon mal Dreizehnter genannt? Weil das ist ja eine Unglückssache. Ich glaube schon. Also ist das im Christentum so? Also spätestens wenn du Pius der 666. bist, das ist dann, glaube ich, ein hartes No-Go. Ja. Aber Dreizehn wäre natürlich schon spannend. Ich dachte, die enden dann irgendwann mal zwölf, so das neue BD-16. stimmt.nte, stimmt. Wenn es Benedikt der sechzehnte gab, muss es auch Benedikt der dreizehnte gegeben haben, oder kann man es skippen? Es gab auch Johannes den dreieundzwanzigsten. Wie, Moment. Da ist noch Skip. Du kannst gar nicht skippen. Nee. Und eins zurück, oder das geht auch nicht? Du musst zwei Namen nehmen, wie Johannes Paul. Ach so, Johannes Paul der Erste, ach so, das ist natürlich fies. Ja, wir sind sehr gespannt, wir werden es hier verkünden. Aber musst du gerade sagen über The Young Pope und Peter XIII. Ja, dass er der Dreizehnte war. Um Glückszahl. Um Glückszahl, aber dann ist mir gekommen, natürlich der Sechzehnte gab es auch schon, aber finde ich einen coolen Ansatz. Und der war natürlich recht jung. Der war jung. Und das ist natürlich auch spannend, ob man sich so einem Jungen zutraut oder so. Tolle Serie auch. Und dann gab es die zweite Staffel The New Pope mit Malkowitsch, Jamelkowitsch. Und da war der alte Pope im Koma irgendwie sowas, da war ich. Also da wurde es ein bisschen komisch, da so richtig Bionicle-mässig, was die Lore angeht, aber The Young Pope habe ich sehr genossen. Schon sehr vergleichbar, Christentum und Bionicle. Ja, fand ich schon gut. Aber auch geil, also diese Päpste, also ich glaube... Er ist dein Favorit. Also ich fand das schon sehr geil mit Pius der Zwölfte. Ach so, nee, da bin ich nicht drin. Da bin ich nicht tief drin. Ich will, dass mal wieder ein Deutscher kommt. War lange nicht mehr, ne? Pius der Zwölfte,
ich finde es aber geil, ich glaube, der Grund,
ich glaube, du wirst mit jedem Jahr Papst sein auch ein bisschen wahnsinniger.
Deswegen glaube ich,
wenn die Leute, die einfach schon
kurz vorm Tod stehen, so wo du sagst,
so wenn du, die sind schon
abgelaufen, so die nimmst du noch mit,
die musst du schnell verbrauchen, weil wenn
Pius der Zwölfte sagt, der nächste Pius wird der letzte Papst aller Zeiten, also dieses Prophezeien, dass du denkst so, sag mal, ich könnte mal was prophezeien, ich hau mal was raus. Mir ist das eingefallen. Ich habe in meinem Leben noch, da habe ich wirklich noch nie was prophezeit.
Also würde ich jetzt mit schicksalshafter Gewissheit...
Du prophezeierst die ganze Zeit, es gibt Excel-Tabellen.
Ich prophezeie den Untergang des Kinos. Aber okay, dann lass mich einschränken. Dann so eine bedingte Prophezeiung finde ich geil. Wenn X passiert, dann passiert Y. Wenn jemand Pius der Dreizehnte wird, dann ist das der letzte Part. Das ist eine andere Art von Prophezeiung. Das Wissen, das sich dann niemand mehr so nennt und er der letzte Pius ist. Genau. Pius heisst fromm. Also das ist ja auch ein fucking, also er hat diesen sehr, sehr wichtigen Namen oder so in der Kirche einfach besetzt jetzt. Er ist der letzte Pius. Und das ist so das, die Macht dieser Vorhersage. Das ist schon geil. Das wird ihm gekommen sein, dieser Gedanke, ich will der Letzte sein. Ich finde es ultra spannend. Genau, es gibt den Jüngeren von den Philippinen, den habe ich neulich gesehen, hat irgendwie John Lennon gesungen auf einer Bühne und so und sehr gut auch gesungen. Da dachte ich mir, das ist wirklich gut. Der ist mir zu jung. Der ist mir zu jung. Kann er breakdancen? Er kann, glaube ich, auch breakdancen. Weil das wäre mal was für mich, ein breakdancender Papst, der einfach sagt, um mir das Orby, jetzt passt mal auf, gib mir mal ein Beat. Und dann ... Papst Hilarius. Der ist ein Breakdancer. Ja, und das Problem, was ich spannend finde, du wirst gewählt zum Papst und du weißt, das war mein letztes Konklave. Das hier, dieser Bums, wie der erste wieder statt, wenn ich sterbe. Ich finde das krass. Das ist schade. Naja, bis Ratzinger gesagt hat, nee, ich tritt zurück und dann plötzlich. Ja, aber er durfte ja nicht dabei sein, meintest du, oder? Ja, aber er weiss zumindest, dieser Bums findet nicht mehr zu leben. Meine Lebzeiten statt, finde ich ein krasses Bewusstsein. Aber das hast du jetzt nicht mehr, es kann ja niemand aus zurücktreten. Aber meinst du jetzt mit Ratzinger, der zurückgetreten ist, ist das nicht ein Dammbruch in der Papstgeschichte? Ja, lass uns darüber reden, von der Meldung von 2013. Ja, das ist jetzt wichtig. War das ein Dammbruch? Jetzt mit Absatz kann ich sagen, ja. Weil in der vorigen Jahrhunderte dachte man, okay, ich bin Papst und das war's. So, aber jetzt denkt sich ja jeder Papst, ich glaube auch Benedikt hat sich das immer wieder gedacht, puh, ich könnte auch, ich könnte auch raus. Er wollte jetzt zurücktreten. Ich könnte es auch packen. Er hat das angesprochen, als er gesundheitlich, als es bergab mit ihm ging, hat er gesagt, wenn ich das nicht mit meinem Amt ausführen kann, dann trete ich zurück. Ja, aber das ist doch lame, dass das mittlerweile jetzt so gängig ist, dass Papstrücktritt einfach eine normale Option ist. Heißt doch, mehr Konklaves. Ich will mehr Konklave. Ja, aber meinst du nicht, dass wir jetzt wirklich alle zwei Jahre eine Konklave haben? Ich meine, die Winter-Olympiade hat es für mich ruiniert. Es ist zu oft ständig an jeder Ecke, egal wo du hinguckst, Olympiade. Es nervt, es sind zu viele, es ist zu viel. Frühlings-Olympiade. Wenn es eine Herbst-Olympiade will ich auch noch. Wo alle so einen schönen Anorak anhaben. Herbstsportarten, wie ich zum Beispiel für Tonschaubenschießen, ist eine klassische Herbst. Das ist eine klassische Sportart, wo du einen Schal trägst. Genau. Einen schönen Schal. Armbruch kann auch in den Herbst. Armbruch kann auch in den Herbst. Wohingegen sowas wie, was ist das für die klassische Frühjahrs-Hacky-Sack? Hacky-Sack. Hacky-Sack ist für mich Frühling so das erste Mal im Park voller Energie. Du nimmst noch einen Hacky-Sack mit, dann landet er im See und dann lässt es auch für den Sommer bleiben. Hacky-Sack und Slackline sind für mich klassische Früh- das ist vielleicht... Ich nehm's nicht warum, aber so Disco und Speer... Ja, ja, kann schon früher., so mal, lass mal im Sommer. So was auch wie Tanz, also mal so Tanz olympisch oder so, gibt ja auch Rock'n'Roll Wettbewerbe und so, Meisterschaften kann man vielleicht auch olympisch, das würde ich dann im Frühling packen. So, hey, Frühling ist da, wir bewegen uns, wir tanzen, wir haben Bock drauf oder so. Breakdance, wie gesagt, ich glaube Breakdance, das nächste Jahrhundert wird das Jahrhundert des Breakdance. Ja, das ist extrem nicht. Aber es ist ja schön, dass das so. Breakdance, wie gesagt, ich glaube, Breakdance, das nächste Jahrhundert wird das Jahrhundert des Breakdance. Ja, das ist sehr schön, dass das so. Wie man über Breakdance gähnen kann, also das ist wie Stefan Tietze. Das ist das aufregendste, das aufregendste Thema, das es gibt für mich, ist Breakdance. Meine Augen werden ganz klein bei dem Thema. Moment mal, gab es nicht letztes Jahr, wo man im Platt so eine australische Breakdance die Schlagzeilen gemacht hat. Ich bin ja voll hinten an. Voll. Gerade riechst du darüber, was der Papst Rücktritt ausgelöst hat. Ich bin ja wirklich in den Zehnerjahren gefangen. Du bist wirklich in den Nullerjahren. Nee, also die Breakdance war ja jetzt neu, haben wir auch zusammen gesprochen. Hallo. Ich hatte letztens einen richtigen Nostalgie-Flashback. Ich habe aus Versehen Apple Music aufgemacht. Ich bin aus Versehen mit meinen Fettfingern, habe ich draufgedrückt.
Ja, das passiert.
Mache ich nie, ich höre immer nur Spotify.
Aber jetzt habe ich mal Apple Music aufgemacht und gemerkt, Moment mal, da sind ja alle Alben drin, die ich mir früher gekauft habe, so klassische iTunes.
Genau.
Als es dieses Streaming, Musikstreamings noch nicht gab, musste man den Alben wirklich kaufen.
Und die waren alle da.
Also habe ich eine komplette Heimfahrt von diesem Experian Rocket Beans TV Event, habe ich eine komplette Heimfahrt, nur meine Alben gehört. Adele 21 war dabei, Lena war dabei, Blockhead, Holbaumann, ganz verrückte Sachen, der Nebraska Soundtrack war mit dabei. Uralte Sachen, super nostalgisch, einfach mal auf random durchlaufen lassen. Richtig gut. The Avent Frontier Psychiatrist, ja mal wirklich so alte Knaller, habe ich gehört. War ich richtig wohlig, war ich richtig wohlig im Auto und habe richtig wohlig gehört. Stardust, Lena Stardust, das war natürlich ein prägendes Album für mich. Und vor allem das Problem bei Stardust ist ja, eines der wenigsten Alben, die das macht. Du hast Lena, Stardust, so heißt das Album, so heißt auch der Titelsong, ich glaube zwölf Songs, zwölf Tracks. Und dann hast du auf dem Album noch mal zwölf Tracks, die alle genauso anfangen wie der Song, und dann kommt aber Lena rein und erzählt über den Song. Das heisst, wenn du das auf auf random hörst, weisst du nicht, höre ich jetzt den Song oder nach zwei Takten beginnt, ja also das habe ich mit miss, nee, warte mal, das habe ich noch, ach nee, stimmt, den Song, nee, den glaube ich, den hat jemand anders geschrieben, genau, und dann habe ich aber noch den Text, habe ich dann, und es ist wirklich so, ey, überlebt ihr noch kurz ... Vor allem das von jemandem zu hören, der Leute einkauft, um Songs zu schreiben. Sorry, aber deine Story, wie ihr mir dann erzählen könnt. Aber da ist immer noch alle ... Ich meine, da ist Lena ehrlich, das finde ich gut. Bevor man da jetzt rumschwabbelt ... Natürlich soll sie ehrlich sein. Du musst dich ja nicht zum Wort melden, dass andere für dich diesen Song ... Ja, also cool, cooles Story, Lena. Ich will gerne ... Lass doch den zu Wort, wer den Song geschrieben hat. Ja, der ist ein riesen Aufwand positioniert. Und sie sitzt leider bei diesen Interviews wahrscheinlich auf einem quietschenden Stuhl, der immer, wenn sie das Gewicht verlagert, quietscht so. Und das ist ein ganz merkwürdiges Erlebnis, aber ich finde, jeder muss da mal durch. Einfach mal starten. Ich vermisse Audiokommentare. Ja, das stimmt. Ich vermisse Audiokommentare. Das stimmt. Warum kommen die nicht auf Netflix? Warum kann man die nicht ausfällen als Tonspur? Wo sind die? Wo sind die hin? Und dann würde ich mir zumindest wünschen, irgendwie so eine Seite, hier dieses werstreamt.es, werstreamt ist, wo man immer sieht, wer es gerade anbietet. Die soll doch einfach auch gleichzeitig die Tonspur unten drunter für Audiokommentare anbieten. Fiegt gleichzeitig an oder meinetwegen audiocommentary.org und dann klicke ich das an und kaufe meinetwegen das für 99 Cent oder so. Und dann startest du es gleichzeitig mit Netflixfilmen. Ja, ja. Ja, okay, kannst du mal. Es gibt manche Audiokommentare, die sind fast legendärer als die Filme selbst. Der legendäre Arnold Schwarzenegger, Conan der Barbar Audiokommentare, wo er betrunken ist, wo er irgendwie anfängt zu trinken und ab der Hälfte des Audiokommentars einfach betrunken ist. Super unterhaltsam, super lustig, hört da gerne mal rein. Thomas Anderson geht während Boogie Nights aufs Klo, muss pissen und kommt, glaube ich, zurück mit dem Satz, ah, das ist Mark Wahlberg snorting Cocaine oder so, also das ist auch gut, aber es gibt wirklich tatsächlich gute Audiokommentare und man lernt wahnsinnig viel über das Filme machen. Ich finde es toll. Komplett vergessen durch Streaming. Oder wir machen Audiokommentare, weil ich habe auch schon einige Audiokommentare. Guter Freund des Podcasts Etienne Gade hat ja den Audioflick erfunden. Audioflick, ganz toll. Also ein Podcast, den man parallel zum Film anhören kann. Tolle Erfindungen, haben auch ganz viele gemacht. Ich habe auch schon ein paar dabei. Ich habe auch selber damals noch vor allem, habe ich mit einem Kumpel von mir auch einen Audio-Flick gemacht. Nee, nee, habe ich auf seiner Plattform. Man hatte da eine Plattform-Audio-Flick, wo du selbst auch Kommentare hochladen konntest. Und da haben wir damals Daniel der Zauberer haben wir einen Audiokommentar gemacht, der Daniel Kübelböck-Film. Und ja, ganz tolle Idee. Also, Sie müssen zurückkommen. Das wäre doch mal was für den neuen Papst. Der könnte das doch mal wirklich in die Wege leiten, da mal wirklich mal was durchsetzen. Sehr gut. Da muss man die Kyrie reformieren mit Audiokommentaren. Hört auf, Medien zu konsumieren. Wir werden euch hier im Podcast berichten, wer der neue Papst ist. Ihr müsst da nicht irgendwie da den Tickern hinterherhetzen. Bitte lindt dich da ein bisschen zurück, ihr müsst da nicht irgendwie euren News oder Zeitung lesen.
Nein, braucht es nicht. Ihr kriegt es hier, kriegt ihr alle wichtigen Infos raus. Ansonsten heben wir ab, bis nächste Woche, macht es gut.
Tschüss, vielen Dank immer an Paul fürs Intro, war ganz toll, bis dann, tschüss.